judge amy coney barrett will meet with
lawmakers on capitol hill this week
after the president formally introduced
her
as his supreme court pick over the
weekend it's part of a whirlwind attempt
to get her confirmation before election
day
including hearings that are scheduled to
start october 12th
nancy cordes reports from outside the
supreme court
i will stand with her
fight with her defending his supreme
court pick last night president trump
predicted a swift confirmation
i think she's going to rule on the law i
think she's going to i think she's going
to be a great
justice for many years to come amy coney
barrett is a 48-year-old mother of seven
who has served as a federal appeals
court judge since 2017
in her 20s she clerked for the late
conservative supreme court justice
antonin scalia and considered him a
mentor
his judicial philosophy is mine too
a judge must apply the law as written
judges are not policy makers and they
must be resolute and setting aside any
policy views they might hold
the hypocrisy democrats worry barrett
would side with conservative justices
on issues like abortion immigration and
obamacare
minority leader chuck schumer is one of
several senate democrats
who say they won't even meet with
barrett a vote
for amy coney barrett is a vote to
decimate the health care
that so many americans need barrett
still teaches law at her alma mater
notre dame
a letter signed by all her colleagues in
2017 described
her as a brilliant teacher and scholar
who addresses problems
without ideological or political
preconceptions
what republicans don't want is a repeat
of the spectacle surrounding justice
brett kavanaugh's confirmation
i hope him let us have a respectful
process we don't need another freak show
no supreme court nominee has ever been
confirmed
this close to a presidential election
and in our new
battleground tracker more than 50
percent of voters in north carolina and
georgia
say that this vacancy makes the election
even more important and anthony makes
them more likely to vote
all right nancy thank you